[Musique]
c'est un chantier d'envergure qui
prendra fin en septembre 2018
ces tuyaux de canalisation sont
transférés sur le site de grand bassin
pour la réalisation d'un captage à la
source
edgar avril ce basculement nos
alimentera toute la commune du tampon
le département de la réunion nous
accompagnons les contenus les
intercommunalités sur tout ce qui touche
les projets d'aménagement du territoire
et là principalement la gestion globale
aux porteurs du projet la casud souhaite
grâce à ce captage sécuriser
l'alimentation en eau pour les 25
prochaines années sur la commune du
tampon et le site de grand bassin
[Applaudissements]
olivier louchard peiné car elle ne sera
que tu vgb la partie de la commune
reçoit seulement donc très considérable
un chantier difficilement accessible qui
tiendra compte de la préservation des
ressources environnementales du site
[Musique]